SCP-682 Vs SCP-2578-D.
The Hard to Destroy Reptile would kill millions
if ever it was allowed to escape and be free.
Would the SCP-2578-D Impaler spacecraft be
able to put its reign of terror to an end?
SCP-2578-D is a mysterious spacecraft with
an immensely powerful and precise proton cannon.
It seeks to protect democracy and human rights
from tyrants, fascists, and authoritarians
through controlled assassinations, or “Impaler
Events.”
One such event befell 682 in containment,
with five cranial penetrative wounds that
pierced its skull during a brief period, leaving
it out of commission for 32 minutes.
It then woke back up and yelled “F YOU AND
ALL THREE OF YOUR MOONS!”
up to the ceiling.
The spacecraft later sent an email to the
Foundation, apologizing that it hadn’t killed
682.
In its defense, though, it hadn’t missed
a single shot.